god it's hot in here I forgot they turn
the AC off over the weekend why do we
even wear suits today
nobody's here I guess I was sort of on
autopilot this morning well as the time
I'm barely paying attention to what I'm
doing sometimes I don't even realize I'm
at work until I'm leaving for the day
oh that coffees from Friday if we're
gonna be trapped here in a holiday let's
at least be comfortable okay we know
basically what they need to say let's
just throw some stuff out there all
right how about this hi I'm Kate and
this is John and we're responsible for a
string of murders across Central Florida
in 2003 hi I'm Kate and this is John and
for the next few minutes try not to
imagine us having terrifying sex hi I'm
Kate and this is John and we flew here
today on a private jet to tell
you about how the environment is in
trouble are you giving a speech or
guiding a plane of a tarmac I'm using my
hands to speak any good public speaker
will tell you that the hands are the
mouth of the Torsen no one will tell you
that but if they did they would use
their hands okay how about this for a
second sentence Hampton Deville is going
green wolf powerful Sorkin esque this is
really starting to come together
[Music]